can you talk about just global adoption
of bitcoin right so the argument against
el salvador is a relatively small
country but can you just talk about
other countries that can benefit from
this outside of obviously zimbabwe with
hyperinflation what other countries do
you think will be next right i think in
the region that definitely the word's
gone out and they're looking very
closely at it so
um guatemala which is next door uh who
is looking at it quite seriously uh all
the all the countries in the region
they're gonna see this country's
the benefits that will accrue pretty
quickly and they're going to jump on to
it and they all have access to cheap
energy they've got volcano energy in
particular geothermal energy uh so that
that region i think in the next 12 to 18
months also you know in terms of that
region is like um
yes you've had a lot of interference and
it's probably not very easy being a
small country so close to the united
states
but
you know the only other alternative that
keeps on being offered is like a very
very left-wing communist sort of
populist so once they see like the
standard of living and the
the situation for the ordinary person
you know their their situation get
better in el salvador i think that could
inspire some more left-wing progressive
sort of side of the equation
uh across the region so i hope that
happens because i don't think you know
going back and forth between
you know communism and then uh
you know a u.s backed military
coup sort of situation junta um i think
you know this could be this is plan b
right this is a a way out of that you
know back and forth
yeah breaks that cycle i feel like you
two are the perfect people to talk about
this next sensitive topic which is uh in
the middle east there's a lot of people
who i think recognized uh
a relationship with the world
superpowers that maybe wasn't so
favorable to their country and so uh
there was many different attempts or uh
strategies as to how to deal with that
right some of them uh thought that maybe
going after the way that oil was priced
would be one strategy other people
thought that being hyper uh defiant was
another strategy some people thought
that being super collaborative was a
strategy uh it usually has not turned
out very well for many of those
countries because it ends up being
violence at the kind of end of the
road how do you think about that with
south or central american countries with
something like el salvador which i think
if you ask most people in the world
they'd be like the country has six and a
half million people like they couldn't
you know they probably have a hard time
fighting anybody let alone a superpower
and they don't think of them as like a
violent type attacking country yeah but
bitcoin is like i said it's the the
market for that is 7 billion that's a
total addressable market of
citizens and residents of bitcoin so
look at the middle east [ __ ] show and
that's caused by previous empires
dividing up on along all sorts of lines
you go to beirut and it's like an
amazing place but
yeah there's dividing lines and and like
this religion gets that many
parliamentary seats and that religion
gets that and like it's just an
absurdity that divides people by these
artificial
barriers whereas bitcoin unites
everybody and ends that because it's
we're we're all part of the protocol you
know
no if you have one satoshi you have just
as much power
and say over the protocol as michael
saylor so like it doesn't matter you're
on the protocol there's no bully there's
no empire there's no dictator there's no
anybody there's just you on the protocol
yeah also
salvadorians there's 30 percent of
salvadorians live in the united states
there's a huge remittance market so by
adopting a bitcoin standard they're
going to say 400 million dollars a year
right off the get-go by going into
bitcoin mining projected to make a
billion in revenues year one
how how much can he transform this
country in terms of like leap frogging
uh
let's say the united states is near the
top right whether it's the top or top 10
or whatever from a country standpoint
based on a bunch of different metrics
and let's say el salvador is uh near the
middle of the pack to the bottom right
depending on what metric you're looking
at
can he leap frog into the top 10
countries in the world well
you can leapfrog onto this new monetary
standard right because you have no money
of your own it's just the us dollar so
they have no control over it anyway it's
just like with africa that they
leapfrogged onto you know mobile
technology because they didn't even
and bank you know uh banking
infrastructure on their mobile phones
they were one of the first there
with things like m-pesa because they
didn't have a legacy banking system so
not having a legacy system
often does allow one to leap frog so
yeah is it really about leapfrogging or
is it more about stepping away from
a falling collapsing building
and surviving so right now they've got a
dollar in el salvador it's a dollar
standard and the us dollar is in serious
trouble as we just talked about and the
us economy is in serious trouble as we
just talked about so
is it about leapfrogging or catching up
to the us or is it about stepping aside
and letting the us
collapse and not getting hurt badly by
it i think a lot of people the incentive
at this point in bitcoin circles is to
escape the
the controlled demolition of the us
empire which is a huge going to be a
huge event in the next 18 to 24 months
but without having to uh jump on some
sort of china bandwagon so that's often
like the the paradigm that is set up
over the past few hundred years is like
here's one superpower and it's being
displaced by another superpower and
we've had what 18
thucydides traps over the past uh
several hundred thousand years or
something not hundred thousand but
hundreds or thousands of years and so
this is a a plan b it's a way out of
that cycle like it break it breaks all
the cycles i think it was michael saylor
that said it